still clown
esque
but not as
clown hello everybody my name is Mark BL
and welcome to what is
that you all right this is the Lost fear
okay oh press e or left Mouse button to
interact you might not have any of the
performance issues but if you do high
quality is recommended be aware of your
surroundings he's always watching you I
can
tell
so what am I I'm
here I'm not here I was about to say if
that's how why doesn't a horror game do
that you have a monster in the main menu
and then you literally press play and
you're there with
it that is a fantastic idea why hasn't
that been implemented imagine if the
game just started that way and that was
just the level I'm not talking like you
get in there and it goes away I'm
talking like it's there and it's there
and you have to do something that
terrifies
me that
was I want to see
that all
right
cool oh
boy okay well they made it as dark as
possible which is always such a good
thing love that who builds a house with
a narrow hallway like this what am I
looking
at long story
short we're off to a great start okie
dokie
jug uh-huh so is he watching me even
now is this part of the always
watching is it in the
audience is it among
you is it Among
Us oh boy we got a
loop okay is this a Spot the Difference
kind of loop is this I'm going to keep
going until it's Spooks me where the
hell am I I don't know oh
oh you going to jump on my head what
even is
you what in the hell are
you I don't know where your ass starts
and your head ends oh boy that's
fine yeah that's
[Music]
fine uh-huh yeah yeah that's
good that's really good I'm happy about
[Music]
that oh my God you stop that [__] as
soon as that goes back on I'm running in
three two here we
go yeah I wasn't even sure if I would be
able to run but it is convenient
floor seems a little
[Music]
loose
uhhuh this
is the best are the walls breathing or
is my vision
exploding perhaps my eyes are
meling good
jug
no oh
no well that's a little cliche don't you
think what if I look up all
[Music]
right
L of uh
oh I'm in
trouble it's going to jump at me and the
thing is I know what it's doing I've
seen things like this before I still
don't like it I still really don't like
[Music]
it
I knew it I knew that they were going to
pull that [__] I knew that's what was
going to
happen and yet here I stand still dun
dunned I got dunned by it they they were
going to do it and now they dunned
it
hello I love
rust rust in concrete is my
aesthetic oh it's usable I didn't expect
that okay but why
though one way to find
[Music]
out squeaky okay so there must be a few
turning
mobs that I'm supposed to
spin in order to get the uh Port
Cullis
risen
great is he still always watching me is
the always part of this still a
thing looked like a
[Music]
boob
great
boy
[Music]
okay this is
fine mhm seems like one
more oh
good do I read the creepy note by the
creepy chair over here or do I go in the
room and turn the the creepy knob with
the creepy chair in the room there are
times when all I can think about is
murdering someone a same
[Music]
relatable
don't you do it don't you freaking do it
don't freaking do it I knew you were
going to do
it I knew that was going to happen I
knew
it I
knew they were going to do some
[__] where they just I knew it was
going to be a screamer they might as
pull as well put screamer
doj you literally have no other reason
to put this here there is no reason for
this to be here other than to get people
that are afraid of Manakin go who is my
Manakin whatever not afraid of
that I'm terrified of that table that
credenza all
right ha that cred really oh God I
didn't look up I wasn't looking oh my
God thank you thank you thank you
appreciate it PR big PR thanks for
taking care of that cenza that was that
was really spooking
me this kind of game is doing the same
thing that like um that uh like body cam
style horror
it's de part all right well it seems
like I'm getting numb to your scares is
that you over there huh I don't think if
you had a credenza then I'd be terrified
this chair doesn't bother me
none so um
uh you seem to be a little too big for
this space so what are you going to do
about
it well I guess I'll just turn my back
on
you go the other
way
[Music]
la
I mean it's not the same as depart it's
just got like the controls are
slightly I don't know it's not looser is
not the correct term but it's uh
slightly
more
immersive
okay why I just blast some steam in my
face why don't you come on what is with
these w w
s who
picked I mean they're really narrow but
who picked the wallpaper that is
gross looks
[Music]
sickly what is this supposed to be a
room is this like a living room or
something cuz I mean kind of got it laid
out looks
[Music]
houses if I make that noise noise is
less scary for
me
uh-huh hello puzzle no all right I'll
just go back then sure hope nothing's
waiting for me at the end of this
hallway
[Music]
uh
uh oh we got a puzzle birds fly north in
summer East in Spring West in fall and
South in winter so it's a trick right
because instead of just going north east
west south you have to pay attention
spring comes before summer I'm too smart
East North West South got it
easy
[Music]
boom that's
West
[Music]
I swear if I put north east west and
south here and it works I'm going to
be very
angry
okay all right let's just
go I'm not that angry but come on oh
that's ominous I don't know why having a
more spacious hallway a girthier hallway
if you will is creepier that better not
be a credenza oh God no oh thank
goodness it's just a
nightstand I guess could qualify as a
credenza I don't even really know
getting
narrow what's the difference between a
credenza and anything really I don't
even know what a credenza
is
room well this is cheerful like a clown
room kind of a murder clown aesthetic
but hello
oh don't mind if I
do
what
goody
key
should be
fine ta
oh that's
fine well if it isn't more of the same
wonder what's waiting me
here still clown esque M
but not as
clown I want to say that wasn't me
screaming that barely even a scream
anyway lixian edited that in that wasn't
me right see he admits it he definitely
put that in and Oni he grabbed an old
clip from way long ago just stitched it
right
over oh you're
Sly you're Sly just all right we don't
need any more of
that Leia in such a trickster
[Music]
hello and now I think I turned myself
around well there's light over there
chair over there Darkness over here I
picked that Darkness I cast a fireball
at that
Darkness oh it's less dark than I
thought it'd be I love gurns see I don't
get this this is a very common theme in
horror games you enter just a random
room of
gurns why What's So Scary About a gurnie
sure it's like a hospital bed kind of
thing could be dead bod on but they're
just
gurns why is this such a common thing I
think people just do it and they don't
even think about it it's a gurnie that's
a horror thing not like a credenza
that's terrifying that's
scary oh no not more G
he hello is it weird that I like the
sound of screaming you all do otherwise
why do you watch these videos
elix and editing in all these screams
and
whatnot can't believe it you're
sick oh no now the
gurn sideways oh no kind of looks like
cenza if it's that way I haven't been
looking up but I didn't feel like there
was a need
to all
right
[Music]
interesting I
oh I'm struggling to see the purpose of
this
room
hi all
right Okie
ducky
uh-huh
good
great uh-huh
yes well that's peculiar should I look
up nope
SC well it gets even more narrow that's
always good
uh-huh
uh-huh oh oh
God you know I guess this is marginally
better than an invisible wall but um
yeah I don't know about that one she
finds something that break the plank
yeah of course I should oh can I oh what
oh you damn
you damn you you magical
chair
I know I didn't say anything in that
last hallway section
but lii and magically teleport me to the
next thing that
happens just an empty room I guess he oh
he teleported me two seconds into the
future man well did someone just
um break a chair or did oh okay I get it
someone broke the
boards that's good probably I'm going to
guess that's
good problem
solved
problem solved all right what did those
other rooms go to I remember there was
like two other offshoots
earlier is this the way
out well it's it's it's a way
out I'll take it I'm taking it
apparently sure hope no one pushes me my
big fat cake down into this thick hole
what the [__] am I saying looks make
that sound way
better Le see make it
worse
oh I
tried I tried to wake
up
but
now I'm one of
them
soon you'll be
too
okay
oh
oh you thir
[Music]
well done I actually did like that I
know I was a little meing on it a bit
which still made me scream and scared me
a few times had some attention to it
which I always appreciate thank you
everybody so much for watching and thank
you Vasco for making this game if you
want to see more scary games I've got
them all over my channel check out the
trailer for iron L it's pretty cool have
a good day and as always I will see you
in the next
video
bye-bye
e